To start this bubbling bowl of beauty,...
...we're gonna go ahead and remove the kale leaves from the thick stems.
Then we're gonna take our green onions and we're gonna cut the bottoms off.
We're gonna slice up the bottom part.
Then we're gonna slice up the top part.
Chop up half a white onion.
Chop up a couple cloves of garlic.
We got our garbanzo beans, also known as chickpeas, and our black beans here.
I'm draining them and rinsing them...
...because I don't want the black bean juice to overpower the rest of the soup.
Into a pan goes the onions with some olive oil.
Once they cook down, follow with some garlic and our spices, paprika and Italian seasoning.
Then we add the bottoms of our green onions.
Salt and some pepper to taste.
Three cups of water.
Our can of garbanzo beans.
Our can of drained and rinsed black beans.
Give it a mix and we're gonna bring this to a boil.
Now that we've brought our soup to a boil, we're just gonna let it simmer for about 45 minutes.
We want our beans to get nice and soft and then we'll add our kale.
Okay, we're done simmering.
Let's go ahead and throw our kale in.
Simmer for ten more minutes.
Here's what you get.
We're gonna garnish this with the tops of our green onions, some croutons and Parmesan cheese.